continent les médecins sont en ce moment
assez payé pour notre richesse
collective
donc on va réouvrir l'entente pour
ajuster la rémunération des spécialistes
[Musique]
c'est prenait le pouvoir un gouvernement
de la caq ou du parti québécois pourrait
en théorie rouvrir l'entente avec les
médecins même si le contrat est valable
jusqu'en 2023
après tout les libéraux l'ont fait en
2014 avec les régimes de retraite des
employés municipaux
c'est un débat de 3,9 milliards de
dollars qu'on ne souhaite pas faire
supporter par les contribuables du
québec nuit le gouvernement a le pouvoir
d'adopter une loi et d'imposer des
conditions aux médecins québécois
mais si les règles du jeu ne sont pas
respectés et une telle loi peut aussi
être validée par les tribunaux et des
loisirs
en 2007 la cour suprême du canada a
invalidé une loi de la colombie
britannique
en gros le gouvernement de gordon
campbell à l'époque avait adopté la loi
29 essentiellement pour casser la
convention collective des travailleurs
de la santé et le plus haut tribunal du
pays a tranché le gouvernement de la
colombie-britannique n'ont pas respecté
un des principes fondamentale la
constitution canadienne
le droit à la négociation ceci étant dit
revenons au québec pour modifier
l'entente avec les médecins c'est au
gouvernement que reviendra le fardeau de
démontrer au moins deux choses d'abord
que l'objectif de réduire la
rémunération des médecins est valable
que ça sert l'intérêt public
ensuite qu'il est prêt à négocier de
bonne foi avec les médecins et c'est
seulement si des négociations de bonne
foi ne mène nulle part qu'il pourra
imposer des conditions de travail via
une loi mais attention cette loi ne doit
pas être jugée abusive
un exemple si le gouvernement se montre
trop gourmand en imposant des mesures
rétroactives qu'on demande aux médecins
de rembourser des sommes qu'ils ont
touchées
l'année dernière où un peu plus tôt
cette année et des ça pourrait être jugé
abusif puisque cet argent là a été gagné
de façon tout à fait légitime
[Musique]